hey guys Ryan right here so I'm gonna be
watching a trailer that I've actually
been looking forward to you for quite
some time now finally glad there's a
trailer up for Mad Max fury road Tom
Hardy is stepping in the shoes of Nelson
Gibson and I am so interested
I'm too excited but I'm very intrigued
road warrior was [ __ ] awesome and Mad
Max Beyond Thunderdome
I think everyone can agree that was the
best one right I don't know if Mel
Gibson's making a cameo or not I like
for him to make a cameo even though it
doesn't really have that much respect
right now but Mel Gibson is still one of
my favorite actors of all time and so to
see one of his films getting rebooted is
pretty interesting shows how old he is
now a lot of people probably feel really
old Eric Bana probably feels really old
since they rebooted the whole two years
after the Hulk came out I don't know
much about it I've seen a lot of stills
and I [ __ ] love Tom Hardy not just
for his pain for balban's but also
because he's just a damn good actor you
know I once read an article about Tom
Hardy about how like he nope he's
possibly bisexual because he's an artist
and he likes to experiment and he likes
to just go out there and experience you
know just try things out for himself and
see how he feels about it afterwards and
yes I've got on my dick sucked by like
14 guys since you know what it's not for
me took about 14 times decided
killing for guzzoline getting close to
the magical free Jasper field Ringo my
name is Max is fire and blood
whoa this film is directed by Lee oh
[ __ ]
today
wanna get through this just release
there
do you have dude
Wow do you this looks [ __ ] awesome
[ __ ]
what's your name
that max
that's cool the original guys behind it
yes a thousand times yes that film looks
like if you're gonna reboot I don't know
if it's a reboot our sequel not not
entirely sure because the original guys
behind it still like it looks like its
own thing like it doesn't look like they
necessarily work are trying to redo the
Mad Max trilogy it looks like it's just
it's own unique being and the way it's
all captured just looks beautifully like
that opening shot of the trailer where
he's just standing there then he kills
the lizard and then those car just shut
like it was just beautiful like this
whole film just is shot beautifully it
looks like it has a like a solid Menace
about it and at the same time it's gonna
be like jam-packed with cool action and
you got great actors in there dude this
film's gonna be [ __ ] sweet Mad Max
more like looking forward to it maxed
copy and those stupid that was so stupid
anyway guys thanks for let me know that
Comic Con trailer is out if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe right
here didn't Tom Hardy cuz I kind of
sound a little bit like Mel Gibson at
first I thought at first you sound a
little bit like Mel Gibson a little Mel
Gibson almost ready yeah that's my Mel
Gibson impression right give him the
Lakers tickets
remember those tapes owe me if you
haven't heard those no gifts an
audiotape said you got to hear them some
of the funniest domestic violence shitty
delivery yeah my guys gonna do some
shout outs here Miguel Torres he wanted
a shout-out cuz he thinks for really
funny um I don't know where you think
we're funny this is a really serious
channel like we're out there to not be
clowns we're out there to get messages
about our opinions on trailers then our
opinions on movies and then show our
creativity with the short films that
really express ourselves emotionally
dude to say we're funny it's kind of an
insult I mean when we did the April
Fool's prank video where you seen my ass
in my pubic hair I was exposing myself
as an artist it wasn't for laughs think
I'm funny what do you think I'm funny
you think I'm a [ __ ] clown what the
[ __ ] is funny about that
dark lord Varrick he actually
recommended the mad Mack
trailer and he wants a shout-out because
he loves the vids yes sir you can have a
shout-out Dark Lord beric Dark Lord a
lot of people go by Dark Lord on YouTube
business mean to be a Dark Lord what are
you guys Dark Lord of are you the Dark
Lord of you know penguins are you the
Dark Lord of juice
are you the Dark Lord of the movie
anchorman where are you the Dark Lord of
I'm gonna assume it's one of those three
categories
penguins Jews or the movie anchorman
anyway dude thanks for recommending the
trailer to me Varrick is I believe I
believe it's an old wooden ship Varrick
is a good name he sounds sexy honestly
you sound like a pedophile Christian
Boris Ryan found her channel I think
like a month ago
I was looking for the evil within
trailer and found your reaction video to
it best [ __ ] ever been hook since can I
get a shout-out do the whole Batman
where is she bit with whoever's filming
with you or with the Joker pop-up thing
well no one stole me with me where is
she
where is Rachel where are they were oh
my father was a drinker and a fiend one
night he comes home waving a knife
around tell me a story two kids my
father didn't like his not one bit so he
takes a knife to mean Ian says why so
serious
that's how the Joker Suga Heath Ledger
had it all wrong he should have that his
more along the lines of what he should
have done
I have sex with this cardboard cutout